within a year of the Gezi protests with comfortable margins.
To be sure, governments have different resources to bring to the table.
It's not the same game, but the differences are instructive.
And like all such stories, this is not a story just of technology.
It's what technology allows us to do converging with what we want to do.
Today's social movements want to operate informally.
They do not want institutional leadership.
They want to stay out of politics because they fear corruption and cooptation.
They have a point.
Modern representative democracies are being strangled in many countries
by powerful interests.
But operating this way makes it hard for them
to sustain over the long term and exert leverage over the system,
which leads to frustrated protesters dropping out,
and even more corrupt politics.
And politics and democracy without an effective challenge hobbles,
because the causes that have inspired the modern recent movements are crucial.
Climate change is barreling towards us.
Inequality is stifling human growth and potential and economies.
Authoritarianism is choking many countries.
We need movements to be more effective.
Now, some people have argued that the problem is
today's movements are not formed of people who take as many risks as before,
and that is not true.
From Gezi to Tahrir to elsewhere,
I've seen people put their lives and livelihoods on the line.
It's also not true, as Malcolm Gladwell claimed,
that today's protesters form weaker virtual ties.
No, they come to these protests, just like before,
with their friends, existing networks,
and sometimes they do make new friends for life.
I still see the friends that I made
in those Zapatista-convened global protests more than a decade ago,
and the bonds between strangers are not worthless.
When I got tear-gassed in Gezi,
people I didn't know helped me and one another instead of running away.
In Tahrir, I saw people, protesters,
working really hard to keep each other safe and protected.
And digital awareness-raising is great,
because changing minds is the bedrock of changing politics.
But movements today have to move beyond participation at great scale very fast
and figure out how to think together collectively,
develop strong policy proposals, create consensus,
figure out the political steps and relate them to leverage,
because all these good intentions and bravery and sacrifice by itself
are not going to be enough.
And there are many efforts.
In New Zealand, a group of young people are developing a platform called Loomio
for participatory decision making at scale.
In Turkey, 140Journos are holding hack-a-thons
so that they support communities as well as citizen journalism.
In Argentina, an open-source platform called DemocracyOS
is bringing participation to parliaments and political parties.
These are all great, and we need more,
but the answer won't just be better online decision-making,
because to update democracy, we are going to need to innovate at every level,
from the organizational to the political to the social.
Because to succeed over the long term,
sometimes you do need tea without sugar
along with your Twitter.
Thank you.
(Applause)